so I'm Mike Dixon I'm amber and we live
in Madeline Michigan I'm a small animal
veterinarian I take care of dogs and
cats mostly I work with a great team of
people they make every day fun we talk
for the animals that's how we get
through it so I work for the local beer
wholesaler and I was a little bit of a
bad influence on her at first actually
she's a much better student before we
met she was a valedictorian high school
and I was not
see I mean we made it through the first
couple years and you know we're the
typical college sweethearts and one of
getting engaged about three years after
we really started dating and got married
right before vet school that was tough
it was we financed cars and we find as
TVs and couches and tables and whatever
you could find it as we financed it
we had two car payments that totaled
$777 I still remember that and was a
little bit of awareness at least that
there's some money there but there was
no connection to the family and no
connection the fact we had to pay it
back in amber actually had a breakdown
the whole picture was I was eight months
pregnant dragging around a bag of dog
poop and crying it was horrible so I
just felt hopeless like there was there
was no way we could ever be done and and
I was eight months pregnant with our
first child so thinking about his future
and and how we had just ruined it before
we ever started you know I was just
hopeless then and that's why I came home
- and that was one of the first times I
saw her crying where it wasn't like
directly my fault that I didn't do
something so I knew it was it was not
good and this time we were starting to
think that we weren't gonna borrow money
anymore we were doing our own budget
those budgets they were a big step for
us but really they were just documenting
what we were already doing
they weren't necessarily say okay these
are the changes that we're going to make
because saying hey look this is what we
just did last month it was more rear
view mirror than windshield it wasn't we
weren't
making any progress Amber's the
prototypical like we list where
everything is it is how it is and I have
just it's gonna work out there's
optimism that has no basis in reality so
when we finally decided you know we need
something more we need we need to really
do this radiant was offering FPU and we
weren't members there we had never been
there before but they were the ones who
offer child care and I remember when we
bought Total Money Makeover before FPU
we read through that and I was skipping
through the success stories because I
was like I need to know that this is a
possibility you know you give me all
these formulas you can tell me what to
do but I need to know people have done
it but doing this kind of give us both
like a plan and realize that when I tell
everything everything's gonna work out
she wants to know how here's how here's
how we're gonna do it an FPU actually I
mean it changed our lives in the
financial sense but it also changed our
lives in our connection with God and and
found us a church and a family there and
it's just changed everything and life is
easier with support from all over the
place I think the thing that we're most
excited about is to raise our boys to
not have to go through the same journey
we have and just be raised in a
debt-free household they all know what a
budget is there's three five and seven
no they all know what on sale is
now almond who got it exactly they do I
do
that's not made for me the hardest part
was just changing my mindset and making
the important things more important and
the less important material things less
important and realizing that you know
you don't have to have those impulse
purchases all the time to make you a
happy person the two of us have been
able to lead an FPU class and there's a
wide range of people that are in that
class they're all going through the same
thing
watching people change in this FPU class
kind of reliving that change through
them and seeing the look on their face
from the very beginning when when you're
sitting there and you're thinking how am
I going to do this how am I going to win
this battle and then to see them realize
that it can be done and there's hope and
there's a plan especially to see
everybody go through and cut their
credit burn so that was a really
powerful part that's exciting it was
really exciting and and one couple every
time they cut a card there was a story
about the credit card and I bought TV
with this one and I bought your ring
with this one and you know it's it's a
professional hopefully you know their
stories won't revolve around credit
cards in the future and you know I
certainly don't we hope both tears don't
need it
our lives are a whole lot different now
than they were five years ago
way different they were ten years ago
because honestly I really don't care
what kind of cars we have right now like
I we don't really care about keeping up
with the Joneses no we absolutely do not
do
we're happy about it well in just last
week we had a situation that in years
past would have been a crisis we have
two vehicles because we have lots of
kids that need to shuttle around and in
the last week mine got a flat tire with
a nail in it at the same time as the
brakes went out on the other one we have
money set aside and so it's going
towards a new truck now and and it was
inconvenient but it wasn't a crisis
we're weird all right